heure de new york andrew cuomo
démissionne à la suite d'accusations de
harcèlement sexuel
il y a une semaine le rapport d'une
enquête indépendante révéler des gestes
et des propos déplacés à l'encontre de
onze femmes joe biden est la présidente
de la chambre des représentants nancy
pelosi avait alors estimé qu'il devait
quitter son poste
[Musique]
alors que les antilles françaises sont
frappés de plein fouet par la quatrième
vague le ministre d outre-mer attendu ce
soir en guadeloupe une de nouvelles
mesures de durcissement devrait être
prise comme en martinique où le
confinement se renforce les touristes
sont invités à quitter l'île à des
renforts médicaux doivent arriver sur
place
[Musique]
en afghanistan les talibans viennent de
s'emparer des villes de farah et de
baghlan dans l'ouest du pays les
insurgés contrôlent désormais huit
capitales provinciales l'armée ariane
est impuissante avec le retrait
progressif des troupes américaines le
gouvernement demande de l'aide à la
communauté internationale
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est 20h bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france et ont
débuté aux états unis où on a appris en
fin d'après midi la démission du
gouverneur de l'état de new york andrew
cuomo après des accusations de
harcèlement sexuel alors pour plus de
précisions on rejoint tout de suite
notre correspondant à washington comme
abonnés
thomas bonsoir alors c'est un dénouement
qui était attendu
oui le feuilleton a enfin pris fin
puisque évidemment la pression
s'accentuait ces derniers jours au tour
d'andrew cuomo visez donc par une
enquête pour des faits de harcèlement
sexuel des baisers des étreintes non
désirées un environnement de travail
toxiques au total ce sont 168 pages
d'investigation qui avait été révélé
lors d'une conférence de presse de la
procureur de l'état de new york c'était
la semaine dernière andrew cuomo avait
alors réagi en niant ces accusations et
puis la pression s'était accentuée
notamment après les déclarations du
président américain à joe biden qui
avait été interrogé sur le sort de ce
gouverneur démocrate de l'état de new
york et joe biden avait appelé andro
comeau a démissionné c'est donc chose
faite dans une allocution qui a été
diffusé à la mi-journée ici aux etats
unis je propose d'écouter un extrait
justement de ces propos tenus par an dro
comme aujourd'hui
je pense qu'étant donné les
circonstances
la meilleure façon pour moi d'aider et
de me retirer et de laisser le
gouvernement reprendre le pouvoir
c'est donc ce que je vais faire parce
que je travaille pour vous et faire la
bonne chose c'est faire la bonne chose
pour vous
[Musique]
parce que comme on dit il ne s'agit pas
de moi il s'agit de nous cattier eau
coule la vice-gouverneure est
intelligente et compétente cette
transition doit être transparent nous
avons encore des choses à faire je suis
très inquiet pour le var en delta et
vous devriez l'être aux siens mais elle
peut se mettre au courant rapidement et
ma démission sera effective dans 14
jours
alors à l'issue de ces quatorze
prochains jours c'est la numéro deux de
l'état de new york qui va prendre la
place d'andrew cuomo elle s'appelle
kathy hochul elle sera la première femme
à diriger cet état progressiste de new
york alors andré comeau lui va cela met
fin à dix ans de sa tête à la tête de
cet état de new york il avait été élu en
2011 il s'était notamment fait connaître
ces derniers mois pour ses prises de
position très dure envers donald trump
en plein coeur de la pandémie il s'était
mis en opposition frontale avec le
président des états unis avant d'être
rattrapé par une affaire puisqu'il y
avait eu une affaire de personnes
testées positives qui avait été renvoyé
dans des maisons de retraite dans l'état
de new york cela avait déjà terni sa
réputation et puis donc ces accusations
de harcèlement sexuel ont mis un coût
quasi définitif à sa carrière lui qui
était parfois pressenti pour un jour
peut être se présenter à la
présidentielle ici aux etats-unis entre
comeau qui va donc quitter ses fonctions
d'ici 14 jours après ces enquêtes et
surtout après la pression qui s'est
accentuée ces derniers jours puisque
outre les déclarations de joe biden on
assistait à des démissions notamment de
la part de certaines de ses assistantes
et puis il y avait des enquêtes
d'opinion qui se succédaient dans l'état
de new york faisant état du fait que la
plupart des habitants de cet état de new
york réclamaient la démission du
gouverneur remercie beaucoup thomas pour
toutes ces précisions thomas bonnin en
direct de washington
et à la une également ce soir la
situation sanitaire aux antilles jugé
extrêmement grave par le ministre d
outre-mer sébastien lecornu attendu ce
soir en guadeloupe où un durcissement
des mesures est attendue il se rendra
jeudi en martinique qui enregistrent des
taux d'incidence jamais connue en france
depuis le début de l'épidémie à 1204
contamination pour cent mille habitants
conséquence le confinement se renforce
pour trois semaines avec la fermeture
des commerces d'un alimentaire elle
décide culturelles et de loisirs à la
limitation des déplacements ou encore
accès aux plages interdit en pleine
saison touristique
les vacanciers sont invités à quitter
l'île des renforts médicaux venus de
métropole sont attendus et pour en
parler on va retrouver anne criquets
aliot elle est présidente de l'union
régionale des médecins libéraux de
martinique
and three caillou bonsoir
ci d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur
rt france alors on le disait le ministre
d outre mer est attendu jeudi à en
martinique il arrive ce soir en
guadeloupe il parle d'une situation
extrêmement grave c'est ce que vous
constatez c'est ce que constate aussi
les médecins libéraux dans leurs
cabinets en martinique
bien sûr les médecins libéraux font ce
qu'ils peuvent et c'est de prendre en
charge le maximum de patients coville
pour éviter les prendre en charge à
domicile
déjà pour leur donner des conseils
évitez une hospitalisation nous sommes
confrontés malheureusement un état
d'extrême tension nous n'avons même plus
d'oxygène les prestataires sont en
rupture de stock donc les limitations
donc sont drastiques pour maintenir à
domicile il faut de l'oxygène pour
essayer d'éviter des saturations avant
d'envisager l'hospitalisation donc vous
voyez que lamont est déjà très fragilisé
heureusement on a aussi un relais avec
les infirmières ont travaillé en
collaboration avec les infirmières
libérales l'hôpital est en extrême
tension avec des places limitées avec
des pertes de change pour le dire
franchement pour les patients parce que
si ça tuerait il n'y a plus assez de
matériel plus à ses personnels un
personnel en souffrance et c'est la
première fois donc merci à la solidarité
nationale de nous emporter des renforts
parce que les équipes sont extrêmement
fatigué sous tension et nous manquons de
matériel donc le matériel est nécessaire
elle est retournée main sont
indispensables on parle j'ai
effectivement 240 personnels qui doivent
pas arriver aux antilles ça va être
suffisant selon vous
c'est qu'une première vague donc déjà la
première ils vont arriver uniquement
pour reforcer l'hôpital donc puisque je
vous ai exposé que l'hôpital et c'est
sous tension mais faut pas oublier que
l'hôpital ne bois que 5% de la
population les laurentides est vu en
ville donc il faudra vraiment avoir un
maillage avec un effort de tous donc
renforcer la prise en charge en libéral
permet aussi d'éviter les
hospitalisations et de réserver
l'hôpital aux cas graves donc c'est
vraiment une collaboration de tous les
acteurs de terrain qu'ils soient
libéraux ou hospitaliers et il faut que
la population prenne conscience que le
moyen aussi pour lutter de façon
efficace et la vaccination nous avons un
taux de vaccination quand même
dramatique puisque nous sommes seulement
à 18 24 % de schéma complet en
martinique donc c'est un taux très
faible et malheureusement nous
constatons quand même 11 décès en 24
heures en 48 heures par dont 35 les
dernières semaines donc
c'est vraiment très très inquiétant
justement cette question de la
vaccination obligatoire elle fait débat
en france notamment dans votre
département vous rappeliez les chiffres
un peu moins de 22 % de la population
majeure vacciner en martinique il ya des
voix qui demandent que les recherches
s'orientent aussi sur les traitements de
la maladie quelle est votre regard de
médecins sur cette question justement
les traitements de la maladie déjà la
première la première mesure c'est pas la
voir donc si on est vaccinés on évite
quand même la dissémination
ensuite s'ils ont des packs signer on a
à un kobe qui est beaucoup plus faible
il faut bien se rendre compte
actuellement en martinique les hôpitaux
sont saturés de personnes non vaccinées
aucune personne en réanimation des
vaccinés donc les débats de dire le coc
vide la vaccination oui non il faut
quand même bien se rendre compte que la
vaccination évite le passage en
réanimation et évite deux décédés donc
le but c'est pas mourir une honte en
tout temps tout vaccin vous avez des
personnes qui peuvent être atteintes
mais avec des formes très atténuée il
faut bien se rendre compte qu aux
antilles nous avons une population
fragile population quand même âge et
avec des prévalences de maladies
chroniques très importante 10% de diabel
une hypertension importante donc il faut
ce sont des pathologies qui sont à
risque avec plus de malheureusement de
comorbidité on sait très bien qu'avec
l'accord vivons s'expose à défend
beaucoup plus grave donc là on nous
avons à déplorer quand même un jeune de
30 ans qui est décédé du coup c'est en
parallèle de la vaccination à cette
décision de confiner la martinique de
manière très stricte selon vous il n'y
avait pas le choix à vous entendre ce
soir
bien sûr on n'avait pas le soin et merci
d'avoir pris ces décisions elle était
indispensable
les mesures de les mesures de limitation
vont permettre d'enrayer cette vague il
faut bien se rendre compte qu
actuellement nous ne sommes pas au pic
de la marque donc on sait que l'hôpital
on passe
la bague le sommet de la vague sera donc
un jeu pour donc je sais que les
personnes qui vont arriver en renfort à
bercy à ce renfort nationale au
roulement et donc encore pendants enfin
je pense que quatre semaines qu'est ce
que vous avez
réalisé je vous en prie pour avoir aussi
un grand joueur des libéraux nous
pourrons aussi avoir un renfort en
médecine libérale pour soulager parce
qu'il faut pas oublier comme les
libéraux sont les acteurs qui sont sur
le front c'est les petits soldats du
front depuis le début vous avez les
infirmiers qui sont là au chevet des
patients aussi avec les médecins
libéraux qui prennent en charge et faut
bien aussi se rendre compte que plus
vous aurez de pathologies qui seront
pris en charge en libéral avec éviter
justement toutes les pathologies
chroniques qui doivent être continuer à
être soigné pour ne pas avoir de peine
de chance ne pas faire que pendant la
première vague ou de plus personne ne
venez consulter les médecins et
apprendre des catastrophes avec des
retards de traitement des maladies
aggravée avec une présence j'ai encore
beaucoup plus difficile nous sommes à
l'umih km avec des moyens beaucoup plus
faible donc merci aux renforts mais il
faut que la population prenne conscience
et de tous les efforts qui doivent être
faits par tout à chacun chacun son dico
merci beaucoup à un trio d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce soir sur un terrain
je le rappelle vous êtes présidente de
l'union régionale des médecins libéraux
de martinique
et puis un jour après la mise en place
du pass sanitaire est bien le porte
parole du gouvernement gabriela talent
était en déplacement à nice cet
après-midi pour s'assurer de la mise en
place de ce pass annie terre depuis hier
les restaurateurs doivent s'adapter à
des restrictions supplémentaires dans un
contexte déjà rendues difficiles par la
météo mais aussi par le manque de
touristes reportage de renault parquet
de robin tu l
c'est un geste auquel les français
doivent s'habituer depuis lundi la
présentation du pass sanitaire est
obligatoire pour pouvoir se rendre dans
les cafés ou les restaurants mais face à
ces nouvelles contraintes
la plupart des clients restent
compréhensifs ils ont été coopératif il
ya même qu'ils attendaient qu'on leur
demande mais pas solitaire en fait de
contrôler en fait aucun souci je lai et
donc je suis habitué à elle présentait
déjà la médiathèque juste en face pour
accéder à la bibliothèque donc aux
moyens pas de y'a pas de soucis c'est un
problème sanitaire donc je ne m'y
contrat pour les professionnels de la
restauration la mise en application du
pass reste difficile le contrôle
s'ajoute à la charge de travail d'un
personnel souvent sous-effectif pendant
la période estivale au lendemain de
l'entrée en vigueur de nouvelles
restrictions le bilan reste mitigé
c'était difficile très difficile même il
faut mettez plus de personnel pour
travailler
pour annoncer les vacances en ce lundi
c'est tous les commerçants père n'y est
pas et pas trop de monde qu'on aime
la mode mondiale
inquiet du manque à gagner les
organisations syndicales réclament le
prolongement des dispositifs des aides
mises en place depuis le début de la
pandémie pour aider les professionnels
touchés par les restrictions sanitaires
et c'est ce fameux variant delta qui
continue de frapper de bousculer les
campagnes vaccinales alors que les
puissances occidentales elle estime que
la solution est bien c'est la troisième
dose elle les autorités islandaises y
renonce malgré une hausse des cas de
contamination variant delta les détails
avec mona hamou dès lors
le variant delta a tout bousculé voire
chambouler les stratégies vaccinales des
différents pays à travers le monde selon
l' oms il a été identifié dans 85 pays
quelles solutions pour le contrer alors
qu'ils continuent de gagner du terrain
prenez l'exemple de l'islande qui fait
partie des pays les plus vacciner au
monde pourtant cet état insulaire de 370
milles habitants où près de 93 % des
plus de 16 ans sont vaccinés fait face à
une flambée des cas spectaculaires les
autorités remettent donc en question
leur stratégie vaccinale si une
troisième dose est souvent plébiscité
l'islande elle analyse la situation d'un
autre angle l'épidémiologiste en chef du
pays estime que la capacité des vaccins
à empêcher les infections des personnes
inoculé est bien trop faible selon lui
il faudrait laisser les gens se
contaminer naturellement afin d'obtenir
à terme une immunité collective en
israël allemagne royaume uni ou la suède
pays où les campagnes de vaccination
vont bon train est la troisième dose est
la solution ultime pour les plus
vulnérables
en france aussi le variant delta met à
mal la lutte anti qu'ovide et le
gouvernement veut vite passer à autre
chose sur les recommandations du conseil
scientifique le président emmanuel
macron continuent d'évoquer la nécessité
de cette fameuse troisième d'auzan très
chaud sur les réseaux sociaux et ce à la
rentrée il est maintenant établi que
pour lutter contre ce virus il faut des
rappels et il faudra vraisemblablement
une troisième dose pas pour tout le
monde tout de suite mais en tout cas
pour les plus fragiles et pour les plus
âgés nous le ferons à partir de la
rentrée pourtant à haute autorité de la
santé et l'agencé européenne des
médicaments prend le contre-pied de
cette préconisation du chef de l'état
selon lagence les données sont trop
insuffisante il est actuellement trop
tôt pour confirmer si et quand une dose
de rappel pour les vaccins kovy 19 sera
nécessaire car il n'y a pas encore assez
de données provenant des campagnes de
vaccination et des études en cours pour
comprendre combien de temps durera la
protection vaccinale
l'organisation mondiale de la santé sa
ligne sur cet avis il est encore trop
tôt pour s'aventurer à administrer une
troisième dose le patron de l' oms
estime qu'il faut suspendre les dose de
rappel mais pour une raison précise
certains pays certaines régions sont en
train de commander des millions de dose
de rappel tandis que d'autres n'ont pas
pu vacciner leurs personnels soignants
et les parties les plus vulnérables de
leur population nous avons un besoin
urgent de renverser les choses d'une
majorité de vaccins allant dans les pays
riches à une majorité allant dans les
pays pauvres pour y arriver il nous faut
la coopération de tout le monde en
particulier la poignée de pays et
d'entreprises qui contrôlent la
production mondiale de vaccins mais
advienne que pourra
c'est la loi du plus fort les vaccins
ont été distribués à 80 % dans les pays
à revenu élevé ou moyens alors qu'ils
représentent moins de 50 % de la
population mondiale les pays les plus
pauvres n'ont pour le moment reçu qu'une
infime partie de ces roms eh bien ils
vont devoir encore attendre
israël et les états unis ont rejeté
l'appel de l'om estimant qu'il n'y avait
pas à choisir entre vacciner sa
population et partager son stock avec
les pays les plus pauvres ce sont les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques qui se
frotte les mains notamment le duo files
heures biotech qui plaide évidemment
pour ce rappel le géant américain et
l'entreprise allemande devrait écouler
pour
33,5 milliards de dollars de vaccins en
2021 alors que l'om est ce prêche dans
le désert l'organisation demande un
moratoire jusqu'à septembre
selon elle l évolution de la pandémie
dépendra des éventuels décision des pays
du g20 dont le sommet est prévu en
octobre si les avis divergent l'islande
serait le premier pays occidental à ne
pas proposer la troisième dose et
defacto à suivre les recommandations des
organisations de santé
en afghanistan les talibans viennent de
s'emparer des villes de farah et baghran
dans l'ouest du pays les insurgés
contrôlent désormais huit capitales
provinciales l armée afghane est
impuissante avec le retrait progressif
des troupes américaines le gouvernement
lui demande de l'aide à la communauté
internationale farah mais qui
l'option diplomatique
pour stopper l'avancée des insurgés
ce mardi l'émissaire des états unis pour
l'afghanistan s'est rendu à doha au
qatar
l'objectif de ce déplacement
convaincre les talibans de cesser leur
offensive agressive et négocier un
accord politique
washington se montre néanmoins flexible
sur sa politique de retrait sdhc leur
combat le commandant en chef nous a
donné une nouvelle mission et cette
mission est de se retirer d'ici la fin
du mois et c'est ce vers quoi nous nous
dirigeons et delà de ça je ne vais
simplement pas spéculer mais c'est leur
pays ce sont leurs forces militaires ce
sont leurs capitales provinciales leur
peuple à défendre et cela va vraiment
dépendre du leadership qu'ils sont prêts
à exercer ici à ce moment précis un
retrait qui devrait être effectif fin
août alors que sur place les autorités
crie à l'aide
les districts qui sont tombées aux mains
des forces talibanes il y a quelques
jours ont suscité d'énormes inquiétudes
chez les habitants de mazar i sharif
mais grâce à nos forces de sécurité
je suis convaincu que ces districts
seront reconquis si dieu le veut
la ville de mazar i sharif est sûre je
demande à notre gouvernement de soutenir
davantage nos grands soldats afin qu'ils
puissent combattre les ennemis de la
patrie
une situation de détresse que vivent
déjà des milliers d'afghans depuis le
départ des troupes américaines entamé en
mai dernier les combats font rage entre
insurgés et forces gouvernementales
avec des conséquences directes sur le
quotidien des civils selon l'onu près de
deux cent quarante et une 1000 personnes
ont déjà été déplacées souvent vers la
capitale kaboul
mais si beaucoup fuient les
affrontements
certains font le choix de lutter contre
les talibans c'est le cas dans la plus
grande ville du nord de l'afghanistan
mazar i sharif
excédé par l'impuissance du gouvernement
des habitants ont décidé de rester de se
battre
nous demandons aux organisations
internationales en particulier aux
nations unies de faire davantage
pression elle devrait faire pression sur
les talibans pour qu'ils mettent fin à
leur oppression et à leur brutalité à
l'encontre de la population
les gens fuient les zones que les
talibans capturés à cause des brutalités
des talibans et elle devrait également
augmenter l'aide humanitaire à kaboul et
dans les provinces
si mazar i sharif ville stratégique
venait à tomber à son tour le
gouvernement n'aurait plus aucun
contrôle sur le nord du pays les
processus de paix envisageable par la
communauté internationale aurait alors
peu de chances d'aboutir à l'image des
événements qui ont précédé la prise de
kaboul en 1996
l'algérie organise une conférence sur la
sécurité au sahel elle a débuté
aujourd'hui à alger pour deux jours au
programme les dossiers des trafics
transfrontaliers du terrorisme et de la
migration clandestine les états
subsahariens espère améliorer leur
coopération sur ces sujets là des
délégations venus du tchad du niger du
mali du burkina faso de mauritanie
participent à cette réunion mais aussi
des responsables de la mission onusienne
au mali
d'une délégation de l'union africaine
voyez l'analyse de baba ahmed il est
journaliste indépendant
une loi qui permet à l'armée algérienne
d'intervenir frontières ce qui lui
permet quand même d'être d'être d'être
au delà de ses frontières et je vous dis
que j'ai par exemple avec le mali
l'algérie
ne partage 1300 km
de frontières et avec les niger voisin à
près de 1000 km donc a quand même ses
cd frontières qui sont pour et ceux qui
sont énormes et qu'il faut surveiller et
quand on sait les mouvements de groupes
de ces groupes armés
dé part et d'autre des frontières c'est
des mouvements qui sont conséquents et
portant
loi sur l'organisation pour la sécurité
et la coopération en europe n'en verra
pas d'observateurs pour les prochaines
élections législatives en russie en
cause un désaccord entre les deux
parties sur le nombre d'observateurs de
l'organisation présents sur place les
précisions tout de suite à moscou de
notre correspondant en trunk l'hérault
moscou ne voit pas d'un très bon oeil
l'intervention d'organisations
internationales dans des élections
internes à la russie le ministre des
affaires étrangères a déclaré au passage
que ces institutions comme la bce
cherche pas compliqué le bon déroulement
de ces élections et même au delà de ça
la décision de ne pas envoyer
d'observateurs à l'occasion de ce
scrutin ouvrirait la voie à une non
reconnaissance des résultats nous savons
que d'autres mesures sont également en
cours d'élaboration notamment que les
pays occidentaux veulent préparer à
l'avance le terrain pour tenter de
remettre en question les résultats de
nos élections nous suivons cela bien sûr
et nous allons en tirer les conclusions
appropriées et prendre les mesures
appropriées
sergey lavrov au final qualifié d'
inacceptable la décision de löw essai de
n'envoyer aucun observateur sur place et
ce à moins de six semaines du début de
cette élection les autorités russes
suivront donc de très près les
déclarations de ces organisations à
l'issue de cette élection pour rappel du
17 au 19 septembre les citoyens russes
vont renouveler les 450 députés de la
douma la chambre basse du parlement
le premier ministre grec demande pardon
pour de possibles erreurs alors que le
pays fait face depuis huit jours à des
incendies ravageurs notamment sur l'île
d'eubée il s'est excusé publiquement
alors que la situation n'est toujours
pas maîtrisé le récit de valentin
carpentier
des cendres et de la fumée
voilà ce que sont devenus une grande
partie des forêts de grèce
depuis deux semaines le pays est
confronté à des incendies de grande
ampleur qu'il ne parvient toujours pas à
maîtriser
depuis le début de la catastrophe plus
de 500 feux ont été signalés à travers
tout le pays
selon le gouvernement plus de 40 mille
hectares ont brûlé dans l'ensemble du
territoire
une situation tellement incontrôlable
que le premier ministre grec a
publiquement présenté ses excuses
l'ampleur du désastre surtout à eux b et
en attique nous peinent tous je suis le
premier à m'excuser pour les faiblesses
dont nous avons pu faire preuve je
comprends parfaitement la douleur de nos
concitoyens qui ont vu leurs maisons ou
leurs biens brûlés
si certains feux ont pu être maîtrisées
une zone préoccupe particulièrement
sur l'île d'eubée situé au large de la
capitale athènes l' incendie continue de
gagner du terrain
plus de 600 pompiers sont mobilisés sur
place certains viennent même d'autres
pays européens
l'objectif est d'arrêter les flammes
avant qu'elles n'atteignent la ville
d'issia où vivent des milliers
d'habitants
de nouveaux déplacés pourraient
s'ajouter aux 2700 personnes qui l'ont
déjà été dans l'île des habitants qui se
sentent abandonnés
[Musique]
avez vous vu l'état nous offrir de l'eau
des collations aux enfants vient il
laisse le soin aux commerçants et aux
particuliers d'apporter de l'eau au
genre
les gens venaient de la forêt des
cultures les olives de l'élevage et du
tourisme il ne reste plus rien de tout
cela maintenant
une situation alarmante alimentée par la
sécheresse et des températures
caniculaires qui ont atteint jusqu'à 43
degrés
pour y faire face le gouvernement grec a
débloqué une enveloppe de 500 millions
d'euros dead pour la seule île de b
une nouvelle réunion gouvernementale
aura lieu ce mardi pour discuter de
mesures supplémentaires
mais c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes rester avec nous sur rt france à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]